foreign
let's go to my hometown h-tone and talk
to Ellie what's up Ellie
hey how are you I'm all right how about
you
pretty good very cool so what's going on
there in Houston Texas
okay so my question is how do you find
the right partner in my case husband
After experiencing childhood sexual
abuse
foreign
I'm only smiling you just like walked
into my living room and you sound so
kind and you're like here's a grenade
and I've pulled the pin and you'll have
a great day so tell me tell me more
that's a huge sentence there tell me
more about that
um
use between the ages of seven and eleven
by
um a really close family friend
okay can I stop can I stop right there
and say I'm sorry
thank you
do you you know that shouldn't have
happened right
yes okay all right good
oh man okay so seven to eleven
um did your parents know
they did not they didn't find out until
I was
um
17. okay
how'd they find out
um
my mom actually read something I had
written like the only time I had ever
written anything down because I felt
like I couldn't take it anymore
and
um she had to go hunting for it too so I
guess I don't know but she she found it
she read it and she
lost it yeah
so they had they had literally no idea
EE okay
where's this guy now
he is dead he died okay how did he pass
away
a heart attack
okay
so how old are you now
I'm 28 28.
how are your teenage years
um
I mean I did well in school I hated
school so I tried to get done with it as
fast as I could and
[Music]
um
moved out as soon as I could
and it wasn't that eventful I mean I was
pretty
pretty miserable I would say through my
teenage years but
um no one really asked anything
we were just kind of like oh she's just
a
typical teenager and then you got the
grade unit to keep people off your back
and you were just quiet enough and
didn't set anything on fire and
everybody just kind of let you let you
do your thing
yeah and I have a sibling who's
a hot mess so
I think the focus is kind of always on
them instead
she had you had a chance to hide
yep okay
so you're 28 tell me how what dating has
been like for you
I feel like that's the understatement of
the day not great absolutely
am I not great I mean absolutely
terrible okay
um I mean I've had one
serious relationship
and definitely was not a healthy
relationship
what does that mean
um I I didn't really really actually
trust him okay and
makes me a little nervous
I'm just afraid that I'm never gonna be
able to trust anyone
okay
foreign
something happened or something happened
regularly what was it
he didn't really listen to me I guess
like he or he listened to me but he
didn't hear me
okay
when I would kind of say like these are
my boundaries he didn't really he didn't
necessarily always respect them
and I just have like the most
skewed you I like I don't know I don't
know what's normal in my head I like I I
see keep other people in relationships
and I see like obviously see it on TV
read about in books like all that kind
of stuff but I don't like I don't feel
like I know what to do hmm
so tell me if I'm off here okay there's
this thing
um by gowitz and maidan and I think it's
oh fear and La Vie uh the two
researchers
and they have this idea called the
sexual self-concept
and it's a conglomeration of things but
it's this idea of of the things you
think about yourself combined with the
experiences you've had
um that create this
way you experience yourself when it
comes to sexuality and
when kids are sexually abused
their sexual self-concept
and for a lack of better terms it just
it it goes to Ash it burns the ground it
explodes right and so you find yourself
um
I am good for the sexual pleasure of
other other people
so you might date somebody and say hey I
don't want anything physical
and then you find yourself being
sexually active with somebody because
there's a your sexual self-concept is my
job is to fulfill other people's needs
or
my sexual self-concept is I'm broken
because somebody broke me when I was a
child and nobody's ever gonna fully want
me
because I'm not I I am is there
something wrong with me
and so you hold back
and don't tell the full truth the whole
truth or nothing but the truth and you
can't because it's a preservation method
and because you can't tell the whole
truth you assume and your body
experiences other people aren't telling
you the truth
or worse
maybe because of these secrets that you
hold these things that happen to you
by somebody who you trusted and more
importantly your family trusted and even
when you no longer trusted Mom and Dad
continue to trust which is unmooring it
pulls a child into two different human
beings
suddenly you feel like if I love
somebody I'm going to be a burden to
them they're going to be worse off
because they're with me
then they would be otherwise are any of
those three hitting home
uh yes
yes
definitely
what is what happens to your body when
you date somebody and I don't mean in a
sexual way I mean like in an anxious
anxiety response kind of way
um
I'm just a nervous wreck the entire time
okay
I mean I
and you know you think like well I think
okay if I keep doing this if I keep
putting myself in this situation
eventually it'll get easier right no
it is not who told you that it would
eventually get easier
I don't know
so myself I guess let me let me say this
um and I can be guilty of this too
the only way through anxiety is
I mean the only way to heal from anxiety
is directly through the middle of it
okay
when it comes to Childhood sexual abuse
and adult intimacy
you can't power your way through it
it's got to go in steps and someone's
got to walk with you
okay because it overwhelms the system
if you just try to just like all right
my body's doing this thing all right I'm
just gonna go date I'm just gonna do it
I'm gonna stand here and smile your body
goes oh hey El you're clearly not
getting our message so here's what we're
gonna do we're gonna shut the whole
thing down right here in the movie
theater you want to watch because here
it goes see right see what I'm saying
yes or you're at dinner and you find
yourself crying for no reason or
laughing hysterically or he just does
like one of those moves where he just
reaches to grab the the napkin but he
accidentally brushes your finger just to
see what your reaction is because maybe
he can hold hands and your whole body
goes into a rage right whatever the your
body's you're trying to get your
attention
have you ever gone to talk to somebody
do you ever spend some seasoned uh some
Seasons doing some
trauma counseling
um
yes
you don't wasn't effective
um
I I mean
I mean a lot of ways but
um
not necessarily in this
particular okay when's the last time you
went saw counselor
last year
tell me about that experience
uh I didn't even really bring up
dating per se like I didn't I feel like
there were other things that I was
struggling with like what
um
well I mean I initially went back
because I was struggling with
um my my sibling has mental health
issues and
um
so I kind of went back because I was
trying to deal with that trying to
figure out how to
navigate that relationship with my
parents like maintain a relationship
with my parents but
distance myself
gotcha from your unsafe sibling so
here's what I want you to do I want you
to
go find a good trauma therapist and let
them know I was sexually abused from a
family friend
for four or five years during some of
the most important developmental time in
my life right under my mom and dad's
nose
and I'm just putting this into The Ether
it might not be true but you grew up in
a pretty chaotic home environment huh
Fair
uh yeah sometimes yeah
so I want you to be very open about the
environment you grew up in
and
just listening to you talk you haven't
made peace with but you are able to say
I was abused as a kid
you haven't done a lot of talking about
what you experienced in your own home
have you
no okay you've got to talk about that
and the purpose for talking through
these things is not to relive them or
re-traumatize ourselves or have to go
re-experience all this stuff the purpose
is because I want to have grown-up
relationships myself
and my parents painted me a horrible
picture of what that looks like
a man that my family trusted
destroyed me
for his own pleasure
and I have tried to White Knuckle my way
through this and I I need different
tools
and so we're not just going to sit there
and spin like a record player but we're
gonna actually heal towards you making
true adult connections because that's
going to be the important part of your
healing moving forward
is true connection with other human
beings
and I wish there was another way to do
this there's just simply not
are you willing to do that
yeah yes
um I'll tell you a couple other things I
would love for you to do I would love
for you to get
um some sort of
movement practice and I know they have a
million different things there in
Houston whether it's a yoga practice or
a jiu jitsu class or some sort of the
body stores trauma in really bananas
ways and if you've ever been to a yoga
class for a long period of time or Jiu
Jitsu class for a long period of time
there sometimes somebody will just start
sobbing
and there's something about movement and
healing and movement and Trauma healing
that works together I don't fully
understand it all
um I just have seen it I've experienced
it
um something else you got to get a group
of women that you trust that you can be
100 open with all of it do you have that
okay
so you've got an anxious body in living
in an anxious environment with no other
peop no other tribe members an unsafe
family
a haunting presence that when we feel
love or sexual intimacy that mean that's
that's our body goes to war goes to
fight or flight
you don't have intimate connections as
an adult you don't got friends as adult
you see how your body's going to be
anxious regardless of what's what your
past is just because of the the
ecosystem it's had to create to survive
and what we have to do is teach it how
to survive in another ecosystem and
you're going to have to get some help to
do that one final thing is
I'd love to see you begin to create a
new identity
here's what I mean by that
one where you are worth being in a
relationship with and you write that
down every day
one where every day you get up and you
write I'm worth being loved
one where you get up every day I am
worth
not being anxious all the time I'm worth
a non-anxious life I'm worth
my needs being met and that means you
have to sit down with a counselor and
figure out what the heck your needs even
are
yeah you don't even know what that means
you're gonna have to ask yourself this
one terrifying question what do I
actually want that's and that's
paralyzing for people you know what I
mean you're gonna have to figure out how
to ask you're gonna have to learn I'm a
person who communicates my needs very
very clearly
mom if brother's gonna be at your house
for holidays I am choosing to not be
there period
I am not interested in a sexual
relationship with you right now but I
will get coffee with you cool
see what I'm saying yeah see it sounds
like Madness to you
because it just seems like such a
strange thing to say I know
it's called Boundaries they're very
strange to most of us
but especially they're especially
strange speaking your needs out loud
clearly are especially strange to kids
who are resp to adults who has children
responsible for their parents emotional
regulation
foreign
for kids who grew up with a sibling with
mental illness
that may disregulated the household and
didn't have parents who leaned into that
it's especially weird
for kids who were sexually abused and
you've got all three
not to mention the things that you blame
yourself for having tried to tightrope
through relationships since then Fair
yes
because you've done things quote unquote
done things I hate that language but
you've done some things that you wish
you had none of you wish you'd spoken up
you feel like someone's taking advantage
of you you may have been sexually
assaulted again
um under the guise of well I just didn't
am I am I onto something
yeah yes you're worth more than that and
I can't be the only one who believes
that
do you believe that
yes yes
will you start
yes
you just cut out on me yes yes
you promise say I want you to say I'm
worth being loved
oh man
oh that's so strange
um
I'm worth being lost
yeah that felt weird to say
it again
um I'm worth being loved
I'm worth having needs
come on
worth having needs
I'm worth more than the sexual
gratification of other people
I won this for some reasons like
that was tough good stuff for me to say
so when you go see your counselor that's
where you start okay
but I need you to hear me say that it's
true
yeah you were not put on this planet
to meet somebody else's sexual needs
you're put on this planet to be a light
and a gift
and service to other people
and my gut tells me is that making the
phone call to a counselor because you've
been through some counselors before
you've got a whole bunch of shame that
you're carrying around a whole bunch of
guilt that you're carrying around which
are Hallmarks of your childhood
Hallmarks of your early adult years
making that phone call is going to be
hard
but in two years you and I are going to
look up
and you're going to be meeting with a
small group of women who have been
through the same thing
and you will begin to make meaning of
the madness and the insanity and the
evil that you've endured
and you're going to be able to forgive
this 11 year old who you have blamed for
years
or you're going to be able to forgive
this 11 year old who's been fighting on
your behalf for so long
tell me you're not are you just
exhausted
very
here's what I want you to
I want you to let that little girl
finally rest
and she hasn't been able to rest ever
my heart's broken for you Ellie
foreign
you just have to trust me that you're
worth being loved and you're worth being
well
you're worth having needs and you're
worth speaking clear boundaries
and you're worth more than the sexual
gratification of other people
you're worth finding who you want to
serve
and who you want to love
and serving them and loving them in ways
that
fill you up
you're worth healing
and it's going to be hard
and I want you to know when it gets hard
and when it gets exhausting and when it
gets scary
that you've got millions of us
who are following you now we're a part
of your story you invited us in and I'm
grateful that you did that
you got millions of us walking beside
you
holding your arms up in the desert when
things get heavy when things get hard
and I will be counting down the days
till you make that call hopefully do it
today and I will look forward to the
next couple years as hopefully you'll
reach back out let me know how you're
doing
um because you're about to become a
light brighter than anything you've ever
seen you're going to be like staring
into the sun
and all that's going to start with that
one phone call to a trauma therapist and
you said I'm ready
thanks for your trust thanks for um
loving Nelly like we all do